President Trump he's making plans to try
to prevent an economic downturn
even as he rejects the idea that a
recession could be on the way for the
very first time yesterday the president
says he's considering various tax cuts
to boost the economy at the same time
retailers like Home Depot Kohl's and JC
Penney warned that the trade war with
China is hurting their businesses and
reportedly may force consumers to pay
higher prices Ben Tracy is at the White
House Ben are officials there actually
worried yeah well the economy has been
one of the president's strongest issues
and something that he plans to run on in
2020 officials here originally denied
these reports that the president was
considering a payroll tax cut and then
just hours later mr. Trump admitted he
is I've been thinking about payroll
taxes for a long time whether or not we
do it now or not is it's not being done
because of recession the president says
he's not worried about a recession even
as his administration is trying to
figure out ways to prevent one options
include a payroll tax cut that would
benefit most workers or a cut to capital
gains taxes which would mainly help
wealthy investors we have more people
working today than we've ever had before
the history of our country the economy
is still growing an unemployment is at a
near 50-year low but cracks are starting
to show including an industry that
president has often bragged about
revitalizing the steel industry is back
it's doing great but US Steel now says
it will layoff up to 200 workers in
Michigan and the trade war with China is
hitting home
JPMorgan says the president's tariffs on
Chinese goods now costing the average
American household six hundred dollars
per year could jump to one thousand
dollars by the end of the year my trade
deals aren't causing a problem this is
something that had to be done
the president was defensive Tuesday when
asked about the impact we have to solve
the problem with China Obama should have
done it Bush should have done it Clinton
should have done it they all should have
done it nobody did it I'm doing it
Democrats now see an opening to attack
the president on one of his signature
issues Donald Trump inherited
growing economy from the obama-biden
administration just like he inherited
everything used life trade deals and the
global economy will be a big focus for
the president and other world leaders as
they gather for the g7 summit in France
this coming weekend Anthony and the
president's trip was supposed to
continue to Denmark but he postponed
that leg yesterday suddenly what
happened there
well Denmark is a strong military ally
of the US and this was going to be a
state visit that the president was going
there for but then President Trump
started talking and tweeting about
buying Greenland which is an autonomous
territory of Denmark as you might
imagine those comments did not go over
well in Greenland or in Denmark the
Danish prime minister said the idea was
absurd and then the president took to
Twitter last night in abruptly announced
that he was not going to make that trip
to Denmark the royal family there which
would have been his host says that came
as quite a surprise
no sail on Greenland Ben thank you very
much